Ferdinand Magellan was one of the leading
explorers of the Age of Discovery.
Often cited as the first man to circumnavigate
the globe, he fell just short of that milestone,
being hacked to death by natives on the Marianas
Islands.
Yet, his vision and his tenacity, despite
tremendous odds, opened up the westward route
to Asia and established his legacy as one
of history’s great adventurers.
In today’s Biographics, we uncover the life
and tragic death of Ferdinand Magellan.
Beginnings
Ferdinand Magellan was born around 1480 in
the north of Portugal.
His family were part of the Portuguese aristocracy.
His father Rui de Magalhaes, was an official
in the city of Aveiro, while the family of
his mother, Alda de Mesquita, were well connected
to the Portuguese royal court.
Both parents died when Ferdinand was about
ten years of age and he was taken into the
royal court as a page boy.
Ferdinand was page to Queen Leonor, wife of
King John II who reigned from 1481-1495.
He was then succeeded by his brother, King
Manuel I.
At the beginning of the 16th Century, just
as Ferdinand was coming of age, Portugal was
the most nautically advanced country in Europe.
She had the best built ships and the most
experienced sailors on the high seas.
These advances had allowed the Portuguese
to take the lead in exploring the African
west coast.
However, the Italian states had already established
land-based trade routes to the East, shutting
Portugal out from this lucrative market.
Portuguese businessmen and explorers sought
ways to develop their own route to the East
that would bypass the established land-based
route.
And so, the rush was on to find a seaborne
route to the eastern markets.
Portuguese explorer Vasco Da Gama made a huge
breakthrough when he sailed down the African
coast and around the Cape of Good Hope and
then to the southern tip of India.
Over the ensuing decade the Portuguese established
trade relations with Indian Kingdoms.
During Ferdinand’s formative years, exploration
and trade opportunities were constant topics
of interest among the Portuguese nobility.
The Crown was fully invested in this enterprise
and was prepared to finance explorations.
Mariner
Around 1505, Ferdinand, now in his mid-twenties,
enlisted as a member of a twenty-two-ship
escort for Francisco de Almeida, the first
viceroy of Portuguese India.
It is probable that he also travelled to such
places as Malaysia and the African territory
of Mozambique.
In the midst of this flourishing inter-cultural
trade, he would have been exposed to a dizzying
array of languages, cultures, foods and trade
goods.
Magellan remained in the employ of the Portuguese
navy for eight years.
He was involved in a number of battles, the
first being the Battle of Cannanore in 1506.
In this encounter the Portuguese fleet of
less than ten ships defeated in excess of
more than two hundred much smaller Indian
vessels.
Magellan was wounded in this encounter.
In February, 1509, Magellan participated in
the Battle of Diu against the Ottoman Turks
in southwestern India, which was another Portuguese
victory.
A year later, he was present when the Indian
city of Goa was overrun.
Having negated the Muslim push into Asia,
the Portuguese turned their attention to Malaysia
and the city of Malacca.
This island city was an international port
that served as a gateway to the lucrative
spice markets to the south.
The Portuguese wanted control over the city
and sent an invasion force to achieve it in
1511.
Magellan was among the invaders, who soon
conquered the island.
Towards the end of 1511, Magellan was awarded
for his services with an award of riches from
an exploratory mission to the Spice Islands
of Indonesia.
He was also given a Malay slave, who he named
Enrique.
This man was to act as a translator on Magellan’s
later voyage to the Indian Ocean.
Soldier
Magellan returned to Portugal in 1513.
He had spent eight years on the seas of the
Indies.
He returned to a country that was deeply involved
both militarily and commercially in the African
continent.
Conflicts were ongoing both with North African
pirates and the Muslims who inhabited the
continent.
Shortly after returning to Portugal, Magellan
joined an expedition against a revolt in the
Moroccan city of Azamor.
Morocco had been a possession of the Portuguese
since 1486.
As a result, each of its cities were obligated
to pay an annual tribute.
However, in 1513, the ruler of Azamor, a man
by the name of Moulay Zamon, refused to pay.
He then led a revolt against the Portuguese,
with the goal of pushing the invader out of
the country.
Back in Spain, the king determined to put
down the rebellion with overwhelming force
in order to teach his subjects there a lesson.
He sent an army of 15,000 men under the leadership
of the Duke of Braganza.
This force soon quashed the uprising.
Within a few years, however, the Portuguese
found that the costs involved in keeping order
in Azamor were more than the revenue received
from the tribute and the city was abandoned.
During the Battle of Azamor, Magellan was
thrown from his horse, receiving a leg wound
that would leave him with a limp for the remainder
of his life.
This was not the only unhappy experience he
had in Morocco.
As a prominent member of the victorious army,
he was awarded some of the spoils of victory.
But, before long, he was accused of carrying
on illegal trade with locals by selling some
of those spoils back to the Moroccans at a
profit.
The accusation was thoroughly investigated
by Magellan’s military superiors and he
was found to be not guilty.
Still the episode left a stain on his, up
until then, exemplary record.
It seems to have lost him considerable favour
with King Manuel, whose sister he had served
as a page boy in his youth.
On his return to Lisbon, Magellan requested
an increase in his pension on the strength
of his service in Morocco.
This was denied by the king.
When he requested permission to accompany
several other Portuguese military expeditions,
Magellan was again turned down.
It was apparent that he had lost the trust
of his monarch.
Explorer
With the king leaving him out in the cold,
Magellan now set about formulating plans for
his own voyage of exploration.
His intention was to find a faster route to
the Spice Islands by sailing west across the
Atlantic Ocean.
He was unaware of the size of the Pacific
Ocean or the length of the South American
continent, and so imagined that this would
be quicker and easier than sailing all the
way down to the southern tip of Africa to
get to the Indian Ocean.
Magellan took his plan to the king, requesting
financing for the expedition.
He used the fact that the Spanish were likely
to reach the Spice Islands before them and
claim jurisdiction over its valuable spice
trade.
However, King Manuel was not moved and he
turned down Magellan’s request, He did,
however, give permission to seek funding from
other rulers.
Magellan set his sights on the Spanish crown
as the backer for his expedition.
He travelled to Seville where he met up with
other Portuguese mariners and navigators.
Together they formulated a plan to take to
the Spanish crown.
The expedition would be presented as the opportunity
to achieve the westward route to the Indies
that Columbus had failed to achieve in the
1490’s.
This new route would also avoid competition
with the Portuguese who were committed to
their well established, but much longer, route
through the Indian Ocean.
As icing on the cake, Magellan contended that,
on the basis of cartography calculations,
the Spice Islands would be found to lie within
territory that was the possession of the Spanish
under the Treaty of Tordesillas of 1494.
The proposal was attractive to Spanish King
Charles Ist.
Magellan and his cartographer, Rui Faleiro,
were made joint captains of the expedition.
They were also made Knights of the Order of
Santiago and given a ten-year monopoly on
all trade in the area through their route
along with 5 percent of all revenues received
from the route.
As a bonus, they would each be given governorship
of an island.
The Spanish Crown put up the money for the
purchase of ships and crew and supplies.
This was a stunning success for Magellan.
Yet, despite the financing and prospects conferred
by the King, he soon ran into difficulties.
Spanish sailors were incensed that two Portuguese
mariners had been placed at the head of the
expedition.
When they heard of all of the lucrative benefits
that the two would receive, they were angrier
still.
Members of the Spanish court, unable to stomach
the king’s generosity to these foreigners,
attempted to subvert the expedition.
The releasing of funds was held up, resulting
in a flow on effect that made it virtually
impossible for the two captains to make their
preparations.
Meanwhile, King Manuel Ist, back in Portugal,
heard about the Spanish financing of the voyage.
This apparently caused him to feel regret
that he had turned down the request by Magellan.
He set about trying to sabotage the Spanish
expedition, sending an envoy to the Spanish
court for that express purpose.
Problems developed too, between Magellan and
Faleiro.
In fact, the relationship between them became
so strained that Faleiro had his captaincy
revoked.
He was kicked off the expedition.
More personnel problems followed.
The Spanish prevented Magellan from bringing
Portuguese sailors on board, despite the fact
that many of the men that Magellan wanted
were experienced in sailing the parts of the
ocean that he was heading to.
In the end, the majority of the crew were
Spanish, although there was representation
from a number of other lands, including North
Africa.
Magellan’s slave, Enrique also sailed with
his master.
A Fateful Voyage
Finally, Magellan had five ships ready to
sail.
These were the Trinidad, upon which he sailed,
the Victoria, the Concepcion, the Santo Antonio
and the Santiago.
In total, there were 273 men.
Everything we know about Magellan’s voyage
comes from a journal that was kept by a crewmember
by the name of Antonio Pigafetta.
They sailed out of Seville harbor on St. Lawrence
Day, August 10th, 1519.
During his time in Seville, Magellan had met
and married a teenage girl by the name of
Beatriz Barbosa, who was the daughter of a
Portuguese friend.
Not long thereafter, Beatriz, gave birth to
their first and only child, a son named Rodrigo.
On sailing out of Seville, he would never
see them again.
The fleet sailed down the Guadalquivir river
and the port of Sanlucar de Barrameda.
Finally, on September 20th, they headed out
into the Atlantic Ocean.
The first stop was Tenerife in the Canary
Islands.
Getting there was plain sailing but, the next
leg of the journey, from Tenerife southwest
across the equator was beset by wild storms.
The chronicler Pigafetta describes many occasions
where the men thought they were done for as
terrible storm winds battered the ships.
He puts their deliverance down to the divine
interference of Saint Anselm, who showed his
presence by a light at the tip of the mast.
What he was actually seeing was St. Elmo’s
Fire, an electrical charge that is often seen
on the top of masts in thunderstorms.
Having navigated the stormy seas, Magellan
set a course for Brazil, which was a possession
of the Portuguese.
But they had not yet established any substantial
settlements there.
Magellan’s five ships reached the Brazilian
coast in early November and then moved south
until they reached the bay of Rio De Janairo.
Having reached South America, Magellan had
to face the reality of the geography that
he had only previously guessed at.
He had assured the Spanish king that he would
discover a strait through this continent that
would allow them to pass into the South Seas
and then make a direct run to the East Indies.
What he found was that the South American
coast ran for further to the south than he
had ever imagined – and there was no promise
that he would find a strait to cut through
it.
The realization that they might be forced
to add an unknown length of time to their
journey by circumnavigating South America
caused tension among the crew.
From Rio De Janairo, the fleet travelled south
to the Rio de la Platta estuary.
There they stopped to allow the men to explore
inland.
Here they came across a tribe of natives,
described by Pigafetta as cannibalistic giants.
According to his journal account, the crew
managed to coax four of the natives aboard
one of the ships.
While distracting them with trinkets, Pigafetta
writes . . .
The captain had the fetters put on the feet
of both of them.
And when they saw the bolt across the fetters
being struck with a hammer to rivet and prevent
them from being opened, these giants were
afraid.
But the captain made signs to them that they
should suspect nothing.
Nevertheless, perceiving the trick that had
been played on them, they began to blow and
foam at the mouth like bulls, loudly calling
on Setebos (their devil) to help them.
Magellan put the other two in irons but then
decided to release them.
The actions of the sailors appear excessively
aggressive toward the native people of Rio
de la Platta.
It quickly devolved into outright combat.
Magellan lost his first man when a sailor
was hit in the torso by a poisoned arrow.
Magellan made a speedy exit.
But, rather than head back out into the open
seas, it was decided to head into the river
in the belief that it could just be the strait
that would allow them to cut across the continent.
It didn’t take them long, however, to realize
that the waters they were travelling were
freshwater and so could not have come from
the ocean on the other side of the continent.
When Magellan realized his mistake, he turned
south, coming to the port of San Julian in
Argentina just prior to Easter, 1520.
He decided to lay up there over the winter.
The rest would not be without incident.
A mutiny was incited by two Spanish captains
who had resented serving under a Portuguese
from the start.
Magellan had the loyalty of the majority of
the men and the dissenters were sidelined
and dismissed.
During the layover, the Santiago headed off
on a reconnaissance mission to the south.
It became shipwrecked in the Santa Cruz River.
The ship was lost along with one of the crew
members.
Just before we get continue to Magellans journey,
let me take a moment to tell you about Squarespace,
who makes these longer videos possible!
The Straits of Magellan
Magellan was now down to four ships.
After picking up the crew from the Santiago,
they carried on down the South American coast
to Cape Virgenese.There they found a Strait
between the continental mainland and the island
of Tierra del Fuego.
It was the strait that they were looking for
to take them across to the far ocean and would
come to be known as the Straits of Magellan.
One ship was sent forth to see whether the
salt water would turn to fresh water as they
progressed through the strait.
It didn’t and the entire fleet headed inland.
Before long they came to a fork in the waters.
Magellan sent the Concepcion and the Santo
Antonio along the southeast channel while
his ship, the Trinidad, and the Victoria,
headed south west.
During this exploration, many of the crew
of the Santo Antonio mutinied and the ship
headed back for Spain.
The remaining three ships figured that the
westward channel was the one to follow and
so they headed down it on November 30th, 1529.
By December 1st they had made it to the South
Sea, which Magellan rechristened the Pacific
Ocean.
Getting through the Straits was an impressive
feat of maritime skill, withy many treacherous
areas to be navigated.
While Magellan was ecstatic to have found
the passage that he’d been seeking, he was
also very aware that he was running desperately
low on supplies.
Stopping to forage along the coast was an
option, but this brought with it the risk
of further conflict with native peoples.
As a result, the decision was made to push
directly into the ocean, despite the lack
of food.
They had no idea what they were in for.
It would be another twelve weeks before land
would be sighted.
The food situation soon became desperate with
Pigafetta recording . . .
We only ate old biscuit reduced to powder,
and full of grubs, and we drank water that
had turned yellow and smelled.
When even the biscuits were gone, they caught
and ate rats – and then were reduced to
chewing on leather cloth and sawdust.
Scurvy became rampant and the death toll began
to mount.
Among the first to die were the two giants
who had been captured a few months earlier.
At least thirty of the crew followed.
Finally, at the end of January 1521, a group
of uninhabited small islands were sighted.
Finding no food there, they pushed on until
they came to the island of Guam at the beginning
of March.
On this inhabited island they finally found
food and supplies.
From Guam, the fleet headed southwest to the
Marianas Islands, which we know as the Philippines.
Magellan was keen to establish friendly relations
with the native people there.
Thanks to the aid of his translator, Enrique,
he was able to establish diplomatic relations
through the giving of gifts, demonstrations
of arms and tours of the ships.
Journey’s End
The people of Limasawa Island, on which the
fleet had landed, encouraged them to move
on to what appeared to be the capital island
of Cebu.
This they did, but unsure of the reception
they would receive, Magellan ordered the artillery
to be fired as they entered the port.
This proved unnecessary as they people were
friendly.
Magellan formed the opinion that the chief
of this island, Rajah Humabon was the king
of all of the surrounding islands.
So, in securing this friendship, he imagined
that he now had the allegiance of all the
islands.
In this though, he was mistaken.
Each island operated as an independent sovereignty.
Still, Magellan headed for the island of Mactan,
believing that here too he would get a positive
reception.
However, the chief of Mactan, Lapu Lapu refused
to submit to the strange foreigners.
Magellan was offended and withdrew back to
Cebu.
There he prepared his men to attack the inhabitants
of Lapu Lapu.
Possibly on the intelligence of Rajah Humabon,
he was convinced that he would not encounter
a large force of resistors.
He was wrong.
When Magellan and his force of about sixty
men waded ashore on Macatan they were confronted
by between 1500-3000 warriors armed with spears
and arrows.
The sailors had the benefit of muskets but
these were cumbersome, slow to load and unreliable.
Hoping to cause confusion, Magellan sent some
men to burn the huts of the natives.
However, they were soon intercepted and killed.
Magellan’s attacking forces were unable
to gain any ground, being forced to fight
from the shore.
According to Pigafetta, the natives focused
on their attention on Magellan, the man who
was the leader of the invaders.
He described the end of his captain . . .
So many of them charged down on us that they
shot the captain through the right leg with
a poisoned arrow.
On that account, he ordered us to retire slowly.
But the men took to flight, except six to
eight of us who remained with the captain.
The natives shot only at our legs, for the
latter were bare; and so many were the spears
and stones that they hurled at us, that we
could offer no resistance . . . The natives
continued to pursue us, and picking up the
same spear four or six times, hurled it as
us again and again.
Recognizing the captain, so many turned upon
him that they knocked his helmet off his head
twice, but he always stood firmly like a good
knight.
An Indian hurled a bamboo spear into the captain’s
face, but the latter immediately killed him
with a lance, which he left in the Indian’s
body.
Then, trying to lay hand on sword, he could
draw it out but halfway, because he had been
wounded in the arm with a bamboo spear.
When the natives saw that they all hurled
themselves upon him.
One of them wounded him in the left leg with
a large cutlass.
. .That caused the captain to fall face downward,
when immediately they rushed upon him with
iron and bamboo spears and with their cutlasses
until they killed our mirror, our light, our
compass and our true guide.
When they wounded him, he turned back many
times to see whether we were all in the boats.
Thereupon, beholding him dead, we, wounded,
retreated as best we could, to the boats,
which were already pulling off.
The ship made a speedy departure to Cebu,
only to find that Rajah Humabon was no longer
friendly.
He had around thirty of the sailors poisoned
during a feast.
After that, the surviving men set sail for
the Spice Islands.
The goal of reaching those Islands was finally
met, but Magellan had paid the ultimate price
in its achievement.
More than 90 percent of his men also perished
on that fateful voyage.
The captains of the two remaining ships disagreed
about the route home.
As a result they parted ways, with the Trinidad
sailing back across the Pacific, while the
Victoria took the Portuguese route around
the Cape of Good Hope.
As it turned out, the Trinidad was stopped
by Portuguese officials, with its crew being
arrested.
The Victoria arrived back in Seville, Spain
on September 6, 1522.
The ship was laden down with spices but the
crew were near death from starvation and the
ship was about to fall apart.
Only 18 men were onboard from a total of 237
who had set sail from that port three years
earlier.
But those 18 men had the distinction of being
the first to circumnavigate the globe